on the same day that the drew brees
issue reached a boiling point quickly
dak Prescott made news that that hasn't
properly been credited for not just
issuing a meaningful and heartfelt
statement about the current situation
but writing a check for a million
dollars to help improve police training
and education and advocacy as it relates
to systemic racism so good for that
Prescott and I'm not I'm not saying that
every quarterback should write a check
for a million dollars but as we go from
words to action this is the kind of
action that someone of dak Prescott
means and a starting NFL quarterback
either who has a huge contractor who is
on the brink of one this is something
they can afford to do and it's good to
see dak doing it yeah absolutely and
also the the idea you know there's
always a rush whenever something happens
in this country to donate as fast as you
can and I think taking a pause and and
dak Prescott doing this a few days after
everything you know was really felt like
was at a fever pitch I just I just think
that's always a great way to do it
because you have a little reflection you
figure out where the money can best go
instead of just trying to throw money at
the first thing that you see so yeah
kudos to dak do you think this is a sign
that his contract is coming he's like
hey I got the money now
no no he's getting 31 million this year
even if he doesn't sign a long-term
contract he'll be fine
but but I think the broader message to
everyone is regardless of what your job
is regardless of who you are where you
live what you do how much money you have
or you don't have there's a way that you
can be part of this change and as I've
said all week long there's no middle
ground
you're either in favor of equality and
justice for all
or you aren't and you got to pick a side
and you got to go with a big
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports